we begin this half hour with an infamous
anniversary 80 years ago today in the
wake of the attack on pearl harbor
president franklin roosevelt signed an
executive order that led to the forced
relocation of more than 100 000 japanese
americans their homes were seized their
businesses shuttered and they were
placed in internment camps many were
held for nearly three years it was one
of the darkest chapters in u.s history
nancy chen spoke with survivors who have
spent a lifetime trying to move past
their anguish
inside the japanese american national
museum in los angeles a reminder of
where massimashta spent his childhood
and these would be
barbara fences and they were a lot
higher to keep people inside oh yes
that's me yamashita was just six years
old when he became one of the 120
thousand japanese americans on the west
coast deemed a threat after the attack
on pearl harbor rounded up by the
federal government they were sent to
internment camps where most would stay
until the end of world war ii the army
provided housing and plenty of healthful
nourishing food for all the executive
order came from president franklin
roosevelt signed on february 19
1942.
what does executive order 9066 symbolize
to you
it was all based on racism most of those
locked away were u.s citizens hauled off
to harsh landscapes the u.s government
built 10 internment camps or as they
called them relocation centers the
evacuees cooperated wholeheartedly
the many loyal among them felt that this
was a sacrifice they could make in
behalf of america's war effort the
reality say those who lived it was far
different
the dirt was all brown
the barracks were all black
and the sky was always gray there's no
color except black brown and gray
giunaoji burke's parents tried to shield
their family they felt like
what did we do wrong
we did nothing wrong
they just wanted to live a peaceful life
they were americans right and this
happened to americans right no japanese
american was ever charged for espionage
and it took the u.s government more than
four decades to apologize it was based
solely on race
for these hundred and twenty thousand
were americans of japanese descent the
people that wanted to come back to
california were not allowed to they
still said no jabs allowed the trauma
would impact generations including
yamashita and his daughter tracy i
turned my back more or less on the
japanese community for many years and
it's taken me this long to embrace it
and be really proud because relaying the
story of the
immigration
and the
war and the camp experience
um
has
it's kind of helped him face some of his
own demons
and now as fewer survivors can share
their experiences recent violence
against asian americans has added
urgency to their mission what is the
importance of learning from history
not to repeat it
a legacy in lesson however painful to
remember
for cbs saturday morning nancy chen los
angeles
that pain still visible all these years
later the emotion so raw 80 years and
then the description gray skies cold
dark i remember interviewing george
takei
years ago and he talked about that it
will never be erased from his memory
they were americans americans